[Música]
otto considera que a gente está indo
juntos em nome de seu link novembro a
quinta feira do ano está na sexta e já
estão virando a esquina é um objetivo é
compartilhar um pouquinho com vocês
algumas coisas que a gente vai fazendo
pra repensar revolucionar também a forma
como as pessoas trabalham esta
tecnologia ajuda a fazer isso depende
muito da gente também é bom
a primeira pergunta bastante num mundo
em que a gente vive hoje é todo mundo
trabalhar no mesmo local tem uma
presença todo dia no mesmo território
exceto horário comercial uma vez e oito
horas de trabalho por dia está falando
de revolução industrial 4.0
esse modelo que a gente nas emendas em
questionar a gente ainda realmente estou
há 30 dias e cachoeiras o brincadeira
depois de ver é só de férias depois de
um ano de trabalho faz sentido isso
em 2009 essa intenção que tem licença
paternidade de 28 05 dias foi fácil
cuidar de gênero tratar as pessoas
iguais independente do sexo da garrafa
delas e cobrar de pessoas já mandar as
pessoas fazer alguma coisa a gente
porque estou falando
o povo em cima de você depois o objetivo
falou que o dia inteiro de proposta
fazer as coisas por que você acredita
poder gerar kia de liderança como a
gente tem
não tivesse esse modelo dinheiro aqui de
liderança que a gente permita nas
organizações
ele falou de fascismo ditadura não é o
exército ea gente é super acostumar
então a organização que eu que eu vivo
no dia a dia a gente tentou tem tentado
jogar isso tudo por lá
então realmente as pessoas tenham
liberdade de tirar férias quando elas
fizerem quando elas no momento elas
fizerem a tem um uma semana de companhia
pintou a oportunidade de viajar que haja
pessoas podem trabalhar pra onde elas
quiserem mas para trabalhar
a hora que elas quiserem isso é uma
coisa que a gente permeia pela companhia
inteira e as pessoas realmente nesse
nível de liberdade
e aí vem uma perguntinha muito
importante
a pergunta é né ele fala olha não
funciona é possível que não funciona
porque é impossível poder
a gente bota pra questionar essas coisas
nossa vida é o tipo de coisa que a gente
vai automático algo funciona assim as
pessoas têm que trabalhar oito horas por
dia
as pessoas têm que estar no lugar
principalmente trabalhando a gente
acreditar que elas estão trabalhando
as pessoas precisam ser cobradas as
pessoas precisam ser ordenados mandard
será que é um livro é preciso tempo e aí
muita gente aqui na porta já está
pensando armazenar as pessoas que
trabalham comigo
e ela não tem esse tipo de oportunidade
mas não tem essa responsabilidade
flávio rio de janeiro o cara de mau
disse só deve trabalhar com gente né
normalmente conectado ao filho de papai
gente diferente assim
será que é por isso que venham pergunta
que o bom time
tô na escola do crescimento mas editais
a trabalhar assim a empresa cresce
funciona
e aí uma das provas que a gente tem é de
que funciona muito mais do que lá a
gente vai falar que a gente adora tem
compaixão para cada cliente
a gente mudou muito ódio em vez desse
meio ambiente
a gente procura trabalhar dessa forma já
que é ser humano
pensando ou atendendo ser humano eu amo
eu tenho que tratar bem aquele ser
humano tratar ele com o ser humano da
autonomia e liberdade confiar nele
aí se ele atender bem o cliente queria
que eu gosto muito de que provocar e que
as empresas de tecnologia de forma muito
na tecnologia
ela é coisa de objetiva é que
aplicativos à tarde o que deseja oficial
mas acredito muito que mais do que de
uma opção tecnológica
a gente tem um acontecendo uma sopa de
opção mas ela só os humanos forma como
interage com as pessoas elas a
tecnologia ajuda muito
algumas coisas que eu citei aqui mas
mais do que a tecnologia a gente tem que
querer como ser humano mudar
mudar a forma como se relaciona o da
forma hoje pensa em mauro que mudar por
mudar
acredito muito no questionamento que foi
um pouco do que eu comecei tentando
provocar vocês na minha cabeça esse
modelo de oito horas por dia 30 dias de
pé e de diversas autoridades
ele é um modelo altamente convencional
em que a gente nasce praticando sem
parar para jamais na maioria das vezes
perguntava aos algum sentido
e aí o brilho que o modelo de negócio da
organização que ajuda a desenvolver
embora nenhum tombo executivo o modelo
de negócio relativamente comum e que a
gente já conhece há muito tempo no
mercado
[Música]
o que a gente buscou ele realmente de
objetivo foi a cultura da organização
que a gente vem desenvolvendo
eu acredito que a cultura é mais uma
opção que você pode ter em qualquer
organização seja na sua amiga seja com
seus amigos
seja na sociedade e arranjar um país e
para pessoas que você trabalha no dia a
dia na sua organização que no fim do dia
da cultura isso é uma só de crianças
relações humanas de idéias que se
transforma numa cultura todo o ambiente
que a gente convive
a gente tá produziu é uma cultura que de
acordo com as peças a gente tem a forma
de se relacionar com as pessoas
o nível de confiança que a gente tem com
elas ea gente tem que buscar se ter um
bonito a disrupção na cultura na forma
como a gente se relaciona como ser
humano
e aí uma pergunta que
o que é muito importante a gente sempre
refletir é a que envolve a cultura de
uma organização qualquer ela seja existe
família que a cultura é funciona bem se
o papo
olha que em casa as coisas vão ser assim
ou então um país uma cidade o prefeito
da história aqui agora nós vamos fazer
desse jeito é assim que você constrói
desenvol cultura da ciência ea cultura é
totalmente uma relação simbiótica entre
os seres humanos que estão ali eu não
acredito nisso eu acredito que o
movimento de cultura e envolve a
participação ativa é de todas as pessoas
que estão vivendo e construindo aquela
cultura então nas organizações que eu
venho passado que eu até certa forma
ajuda a desenvolver e principalmente a
minha a gente faz um processo de revisão
e fortalecimento é construção dessa
cultura sempre com todas as pessoas
envolvidas
então pra vocês terem pouco de noção do
nível de transparência coletividade a
gente possa tentar promover um bar
quando você nunca tem certeza que está
promovendo 100% é um esforço contínuo
todas as informações que a gente manda
pra investidores acionistas exatamente
alta confidencialidade sempre
compartilhei também com o jovem aprendiz
da empresa pessoas mais jovens pessoas
que em muitas residências nem tenha do
que elas estão recebendo o presidente
fez questão de compartilhar informação
com ela
e aí o que eu queria deixar um pouco de
provocação aqui é descobrir a cultura de
você
a cultura do ambiente que vocês estão
vendo organização cidade família é e
apático luta construção e fortalecimento
dessa cultura crenças valores
compartilhados é marco que compartilhar
os valores praticados
isso é um erro muito comum das
organizações escreveram os valores na
parede mas não entender se de fato eles
valores são praticados pelas pessoas que
achar sua grandiosidade em alguns
autores administração que eu gosto muito
da companhia de lei que provar ao longo
do tempo que empresas vencedores são
aquelas empresas com cultura forte então
é muito interessante é ver algumas novas
palestras é de pessoas que acreditam
nisso não com uma naturalidade
quando você desenvolve organização que a
relação humana ela é verdadeira
as pessoas têm tensas muito claras é
incomum que elas praticam aquelas
crianças
além das pessoas tirei muito bem para
trabalhar essas organizações foi falado
aqui hoje eu acredito muito nisso
a gente trabalha o que faz com que
qualquer outra coisa na vida é essas
empresas já se acham propósito se torna
os mais do que grandes grandiosas e não
só são ótimos lugares para se trabalhar
para viver como conseqüentemente os
resultados funciona o macho é uma
conseqüência
então vejo você buscar o resultado que
você só você pode ficar te fortaleza
cultura forte para que aí sim você
consiga resultados e aí o que eu queria
deixar recado final é um valor que a
gente tenta de novo é sempre um
exercício a gente nunca com as relações
humanas
a gente nunca atingir o status que
tentar sempre exercitando e buscando
melhorar é
procure lugares que vocês alguém diz
vocês venham a conviver seja de novo
a organização que você trabalha as
pessoas que você convive mais que você
possa ser chefe desse vídeo é o mundo
hoje muito avançado para a gente pensar
em ser cobrado mandado ser regidas nos
horários como e onde você vai trabalhar
principalmente com a ajuda da tecnologia
que vai melhorar mais imagens marcadas e
repensar esse a gente poder fazer as
nossas escolhas então principalmente
quem trabalha com empresas de tecnologia
mas já trabalhando praticamente qualquer
corporação hoje porque qualquer
corporação tem que estar integrada
tecnologia você pode perfeitamente
domingo à noite está trabalhando está
respondendo emails mandando uma mensagem
a esap fazendo uma busca preparação do
seu trabalho e aí na segunda feira 3
horas da tarde
se você quiser ir à academia por que
você acha que é melhor pra você academia
você quiser ir à praia neste horário
por que não hoje você pode perfeitamente
está sendo altamente produtivo no
domingo à noite ea pergunta que eu faço
é se você está feliz com o que você faz
você sente prazer porque você está
produzindo para a sociedade porque você
não pode trabalhar domingo à noite desta
quinta disciplina
você nunca esqueçam no episódio eu
estava de férias com amigos em moscou e
quando fui ver estava trabalhando e aí a
gente está trabalhando em conjunto com a
fazenda não considera ser um problema
da mesma forma como eu tô muitas vezes
no rio de janeiro onde mora e realmente
terça-feira 2 horas da tarde eu vou pra
mim porque o circuito tem essa liberdade
estou produzindo como um todo porque eu
preciso produzir terça feira
à tarde principalmente no mundo que a
gente vive hoje que permitiu ter um
nível de produtividade igual ou talvez
até maior
se eu estiver trabalhando no sábado à
noite em carros ou do vale do silício ea
gente mais automático segunda-feira 9
horas começou sexta-feira seis horas
terminou no final de semana teve
software minhas férias eu não posso
mexer nada eu tento tirar 30 dias de
férias porque eu só posso tirar férias
depois de um ano porque o carro nacional
disso é automático a gente não pensa
nessas coisas tomem mercado final e
tentar na medida do possível que
normalmente também sai site que você
saiba nem provocação como assim
poxa mais lá seu país na organização do
chefe para falar assim você tá doido
embora exceto o que foi falado aqui hoje
começa a plantar essa semente eu faço
isso para vocês mesmo confessou
contaminando o ambiente vocês vivem com
minando as relações humanas e quem sabe
a gente não consegue sair desse modo
automático que a gente mas aprendi mas a
gente pode aprender é isso obrigado
pessoal com domingo a todos
[Aplausos]
rio
[Música]